el salvador
is on an absolute tare not exactly the
words that most people thought you would
hear in 2021 el salvador was the very
first country to make bitcoin legal
tender it was the first country to hold
bitcoin on its balance sheet and in its
reserves they have
after passing the legislation to create
bitcoin as legal tender they also have
launched the civo wallet which is the uh
mobile wallet that allows citizens in
the country to buy bitcoin hold bitcoin
and send bitcoin they get to do that
completely for free
over one million people have already
downloaded it and onboarded onto the
chivo wallet and by proxy onto the
lightning network
but last night while everyone was asleep
in their beds me included i was nice and
cold my eight-sleep mattress
the president of el salvador decided
he's gonna shake up the world and he
tweeted at 12 53 a.m eastern we just
bought the dip 150 new coins el salvador
now holds 700 coins hashtag
bitcoin the president of el salvador is
buying the dip that's what happened he
bought 150 new bitcoin for a total of
700 but he couldn't stop there no way no
how he then tweeted and he said
they can never beat you if you buy the
dips
confirming that el salvador specifically
is buying the dip a nation state is
buying the dip absolutely incredible and
then he finished it up with one of the
all-time trolls
presidential advice
not financial advice but presidential
advice and so el salvador last night
continues to add to the bitcoin that
they hold they now hold 700 total
bitcoin which is pretty incredible they
have already
launched the app they already have
onboarded a million people they've
already bought bitcoin every single
thing that people were worried about in
terms of was this all talk and no action
has been disproven
the president and the country have both
continued to execute
now you can say what you want about the
president about his political party
about the way that they do other things
i'm not an expert in any of that john
isn't either salvadorean politics should
be left to the salvadorian people
but it's pretty incredible to watch in
real time while the president of a
nation state
buys the bitcoin dip now remember
bitcoin's price has fallen this morning
it's fallen all the way back to the
prices not seen since august a whole 60
days ago
and when you look at it bitcoin right
now is trading around 43 000 44 000
ether is trading around three thousand
and then you go down the list and there
are all kinds of price drops eight nine
ten twelve thirteen percent drops across
the market
but the president of el salvador sees
this as a buying opportunity he also by
the way has changed the title or his bio
on twitter to say
the dictator of el salvador which
everyone is up in arms about freaking
out yelling and screaming pointing and
yelling and saying look what a bad guy
this is
it's pretty obvious that if the opposing
political party keeps calling him a
dictator he's trolling them
and so this is where the world is headed
is you have a young
president who has risen to power he
comes from outside of the political
realm for the most part and not only
does he understand the internet and his
ability to communicate to his own people
but also to the world and use that as a
marketing platform
but he also understands internet humor
and trolling and being able to
poke fun at
opponents or himself etc on top of that
he has embraced a digital decentralized
currency like bitcoin and is buying the
dip
probably one of the best stories from
the weekend is a nation state again
buying the dip in real time yeah this
has been a big month for el salvador and
bitcoin in general this is within the
last three weeks this is the second time
he's and quote unquote bought the dip
right so it's interesting to see i love
the transparency that he's giving um
el salvador as a country has gone
through a lot of stuff but it's uh it's
interesting they are
innovating this technology space um and
we'll we'll just continue to see this i
do like how he's using social media as a
form of press conference because i think
it gives a lot of speed and reach uh in
real time right a lot of people use
twitter for real-time information so
using that as a tool is just like
another tool in this toolkit to get the
information out
when we think about buying the dip i
think most people think uh okay that's
no different than individuals literally
this morning on twitter buy the dip
buy the dip was trending on twitter in
the united states so like this isn't
just a crypto specific thing this is
people talking about the stock market
talking about the uh crypto market etc
but to have a nation state openly not
only doing it but then immediately at
1253 a.m eastern tweeting it from the
president
that's to me what is so incredible here
is that you're actually getting a uh um
kind of an amplification from the
president around buying it right well
could this be like the new norm right
look i think that as younger and younger
people rise to power of course they're
going to communicate on the platforms
that they deem to be most valuable right
and so uh if you look everyone knows
that i believe that the rock will become
president one day
the rock's probably not going to be
sending faxes right he's probably not
going to be doing all of the traditional
stuff exclusively he'll still do that
stuff but if the rock was president what
would he be doing he'd be tweeting and
posting on instagram and he'd probably
be posting at four o'clock in the
morning being like i'm in the
the uh what does he call it the iron
jungle or whatever iron paradise iron
paradise right with his half sleeve
shirt on
saying if any of you bad guys out there
want to mess with the rock i'll tell you
what's cooking well how many how many
people do you think have notifications
on for a white house press release right
versus notifications on just four we'll
use the white house example for biden's
tweets probably a lot more for his
tweets in the actual white house press
conference oh for sure for sure it's an
easy way to get information out quickly
and um
it also kind of leaves them the idea to
spin their own narrative yeah so the
other thing that's gone on is the
salvadorian government has not only
worked to install the chivo wallet atms
so there's the chivo wallet which is the
software uh wallet that you can actually
download over a million people have done
that already you get 30 of bitcoin when
you do it they also have installed atm
machines across the country but they
additionally have installed now 50
commission free chivo atms in 10 us
locations which is really interesting
because now what you have is you have
atms within the united states that are
completely commission free free to use
and they're in places like los angeles
san francisco dallas doral atlanta
chicago etc and so what they're
essentially trying to do is they're
trying to identify where is it likely
that people from el salvador live in the
united states let's put atms there so
they now have the ability to go to the
atm commission free and remit
money from the united states back to el
salvador and completely cut out the
western unions and other high charging
rent seeking middlemen and to me
this speaks to a much much more
strategic plan than simply oh we created
an app and told our citizens to download
it when you start to put actual atms in
other countries like the united states
and say hey we are going to make this
even easier we're going to make this
even cheaper
for salvadorians in the united states to
send money back home
something tells me that this might work
yeah this is just kind of amplifying
bitcoin's reach and the reach that um
and the adoption of bitcoin right so one
thing i want to note about putting them
in u.s cities i thought was interesting
was there was in 2017 there was around
2.3 million people from like el salvador
el salvadorian descent in the united
states most of them actually located in
washington dc and it was interesting
that he did not put one in washington dc
and i think it's based on legislation
and kind of the rules that you're
actually not allowed to put one in that
um country but it we'll see wait wait
you're not allowed to put one in water
in washington dc in that in that country
which isn't a state which isn't a which
isn't a state but it is a region that
has some of the um highest i guess
density for the el salvadorian um people
from that descent got it so people who
are from el salvador there's a high
density they live in washington dc but
they can't put an actual atm there
because of regulation i don't know if
they can't because of regulation but
they didn't oh they they have not yet
put one they have not one yeah there's
something that tells me if they tried to
install a chivo atm outside of uh you
know uh the senate
they might not be too thrilled about
that um i asked everyone in the comments
i said what do you think about the el
salvador news um and most people are
simply like so tristan inglis who by the
way was one of the uh bitcoin winners
we'll be receiving bitcoin today uh said
that it's great taking out the high
remittance fees right so the whole idea
of just get the fees down help these
people reduce friction to be able to
take money from the united states from
people who are working hard and earning
a living and remit it back home really
important um and then a couple of other
folks saying uh i wish that australia
would do the same thing or and then uh
others saying that i am uh not so
interested in the news doesn't really
affect me um and uh then i think folks
asking the question what country will be
next and to me remember the the special
part of el salvador is that it is a
dollarized country so it's able to do
this uh making bitcoin legal tender
alongside the us dollar without actually
hurting their own currency so we're
going to look for a country that's got
very similar um kind of aspects to it to
be able to pull it off yeah well those
are remittance fees are very very
important right especially when you're
sending it to a less affluent country
and people uh it's it's super super
important in the sense of
like western union what do they take
three percent on both sides takes six
percent of the money being sent i was
talking to a guy this weekend um
he was from bolivia and he was basically
claiming he was like dude every time i i
send money to bolivia i spend hundreds
of dollars just to send the money back
home
and that that just can't be the way i'm
glad this is getting instituted i'm glad
we're kind of moving more towards a way
of uh of more like convenience and
helping people on a cheaper note rather
than these large corporations just
taking a big chunk of money completely
agree what's up guys bang bang thanks so
much for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]